you
okay all right we have a crew of 39 in
this one this one is starting in 11
draught better thank you for subscribing
all right 40 total players for a king of
the hill tournament fourth tournament in
a row now just like regular chess with
one
very important detail
get here with your king and you
automatically win already let's resolve
this pin right now before that night
hurts me in fact I don't want to see the
night even
have the option to jump in there so
let's take them out
yeah you know king of the hill
I it might be the case I like king of
the hill better then three check
sometimes
and make yeah there's some there's some
interesting games with king of the hill
three check is so much more violent
really end fast and three check this one
like when neither of us are getting to
the center anytime soon
I'll take care
ciao
do I do this move I'll go I'll go for
that I
I'm not letting the King get here so
that's a nice nice little in-betweener
there might as well hunt down a pond
no I just want to get on the F file and
hmm you know I don't want to take takes
I'm fearing stuff
that's kind of interesting
here I don't want to take
my rook is in a good position just just
cutting off the king whoa
oh we don't have to lose that
here the king can't get to these squares
anytime I take their down on time yeah I
guess there's also a lot more losses on
time in the king of the hill
okay smokey
opponent
ah
all righty
just be a developer
I think this is it's extremely important
to establish some some pawn in the
center for sure
efore is a good starting point
how does the King get castled step up
this bishop cutting in
doing this to secure efore let's ask the
bishop a question
okay well here here I think I just want
to take with the pawn
because the F file I want to have that
to play with now let's jump in
take with the bishop
allow this this pond to become mobile
because then maybe the king can and rush
on in there
now we're getting the Queen trick for
now now I'm okay the Queen cannot be
removed from this square let's give a
check might be mating soon if the King
steps up and we are back to tournament
all the cap is in there a very
underrated cap cap stir happe stir
whippy is there is that plaster hippie
that was in the twitch chat just a
moment ago knife is in there
who else okay somebody just finished
their knife I think just jumped on up
there
against knife next
still a boatload of time okay knife next
opponent a Sicilian
okay knife is in first where am I fourth
okay is another Gaiman
all right
all going
I want to get enough for
now let's take
maybe I I just take straight away
yeah
let's keep the tension
huh I like this square all of a sudden
93
hmm
let's still get there
they take as soon as my bishop was
blocked sneaky
the king is getting a little bit too
close
yes here
hmm
be very careful um that's a night
Oh
oh boy
no I don't have any time
think I could get away with taking there
I got to maintain that bishop I should
take in the poem how to take with the
pawn can't get let the King it there
they could have they couldn't pin they
could have pinned my night and I flushed
that King away I think am i right now
the king is one step away but my pawns
are controlling all the key squares and
I am okay now
oh man I went into the tank could I have
captured that night I think the king was
gonna step up the Queen could then move
and then the king could get to e5 I
don't know if I could have stopped that
I think I'm getting cap next no it's in
a game
let's try okay that's different
computer plays this the few games that
I've played King in the hill against the
computer computer plays the center
counter Scandinavian
okay I'm not
our way from
getting my King to the center just three
I wouldn't mind seeing a queen exchange
be like I could attack though
Oh miss that I'm on that square
let's let's go for a mating attack Queen
takes h3o right here this is min once
rat rook takes g3 I had I had
it's a pin aroni night asked a block
in the resign back to tournament land
1500 we slipped up it's not in a game
okay here we are okay he smoked oh he's
he's berserk me
yes he is
he smoked me in the in the last in the
regular chess
okay
and I got to do something in the center
are either of our kings going to get to
the center anytime soon
okay I think that this should be
pretty good for me even though I'm down
upon
now they could take
you
take their
let's go here yeah I feel like I should
have some mate now
actually made I'm controlling that
square okay tough player for sure
and that's is that's like a Ferrari like
you you're scared to even a berserker
those players it's just like you're
signing up to signing up for checkmate
doing that thing he had 42 seconds and I
had zero seconds when we played regular
chest and that forget what tournament
was one or two first or second
tournament anyhow very strong player
goes back quite a ways to the chest cube
days
okay
f-five is that much more appealing
did a video not long ago
that night on f5 killers its Queen Queen
dead
she's a good
let's just back up
that's a discovery
well it's just complete development I
want to hold this pawn
no the naik in a block no
okay let's just remove some material
bishop
still on the bishop
thank Bishop d6 you have to do
here I have that there really in the
think tank um I'm getting everything now
we'll just take he's knock into these
sealed
trying
let's flush them away
those to me
time okay 20 with fire two players 20
with fire and just under 20 to go
another first-time opponent let's try
Sicilian why not Wow okay
ah this should not be allowed cannot get
away with this kind of stuff it's too
risky too much fuel on the board nowhere
you
that said let's just be conservative
look at this King he is quite the guy
can tell you gonna go here if there's
ever a capture I mean I have an
additional piece controlling this square
he's definitely doing something fancy
now you have to go back what you're
gonna get made
King here and then mate
I could take twice where's the mate
should be yummy
check and check me here right
and covered
in here b5 mate next think I had that
right twenty fours to twenty fours
fifty-five are now in here okay
trojan 98 hey let's go trojan
two pounds in the center a regular chest
king of the hill three check it's all
good
central control especially wrecking of
the hill
okay I will take care why the night
takes and that I'm gonna be in some
trouble that wasn't a good decision when
I did there that was an opportunity to
take advantage of the pin
they didn't
okay this weird opposite color bishops
and symmetrical structure
in differences the bishop posts the
queen posts
I guess we'll sneak up
rukia's pretty serious skewer oh we got
it
getting some material now
take care I just want to cry Oh
okay yeah I was probably waiting for me
but I figured they'd still just play it
out a little bit all right I think you
just finished no we're not getting that
pairing number two guy I have fire 28
with fire
ah let's let's give him some space think
the space is extra valuable for king of
the hill especially getting a pawn on e5
okay
I get to secure my Center probably
should not have a played night to be
five like that
let's let's reinforce e5 Queen here is
not working because of c4
I just like I should go with the regular
chess approach here Bishop h6 go for me
maybe I should do that one move sooner
okay they're not ducking the dark square
bishop exchange
I'll take with the piece I do not want
to allow night be five so
and actually listen no no no I want to
keep my queen here for a moment yeah
there's that move tell me what I'm gonna
want to go here with g5 and then and
then here that'll really flush the King
back oh this is a nice move Queen takes
is losing take with check and then
there's no defense for the rook so you
have to go back
I'll take now like this should I be
gaining control over the C file or no no
no no no c5 I did this in the last
standard game
this kind of maneuver focusing on the
the weak square so I have spaced the
better Bishop in a really nice square
here that I should make use of right now
no no no get here first I'm really down
on time
oh I'm forgetting what the objective is
its king of the hill what am i doing I'm
not getting to the center
- here with check
keep the king cut off he's cut off
how do I get to the center
Oh God
yes I got it here next Wow I got way too
caught up in these positional factors in
that game oh look at the c5 square who
cares it's not one in the force center
get your king there buddy d5
Queen pong game
ah
[Music]
already efore or not before it is
so these when there's no pawns fixed in
the center this is where these little
mad dashes scare me
I think they're kind of serious the
Kings running up in these in these
positions so let's just let's just put
the Queen right in the center and
say I control all four that's all I want
to do
clean exchange
No No
want that
could have captured here you're really
you're insisting
what
oh boy it's getting a little too
dangerous I can't let the King get here
or here I have it oh I had a I had a
beaut no I didn't have a beautiful if I
played here there's this
hang on I have to guard this square this
is held together by a thread a pretty
important defender I'd say
and I still have everything
covered I do barely there down on time
seven six double-check he's flushed back
I'm happy now
fear
I control the center and now my king
gets to play ball I don't need to down
on time 36 whoa okay are we gonna get a
pairing or not 36 36 26 Xena game he's
in a game
59 players
they're already
let's see who we get next
the cap
okay well
for Bishop c5 I think that's a very good
sacrifice
okay
get some moves in fast
back up
let's see let's see how they're gonna
capture first let's go like this
yes just centralized no no no I
shouldn't have done that I want to keep
my king closer
it's babysit this I have to control the
night taking with the pond no no
ah their king is too strong their King
is way too strong I need pawns around
here
the king is really strong I need to make
sure this pawn cannot be eliminated
I have I have control here though right
my king is kind of sectioned off don't
even want to take that pawn I think I do
working a check he's flushed back ok I'm
making one threat
Capri move that right here one of these
two I'm getting it I'm getting it I'm
getting it I got it here I take only a
way to stop King here is what the rook
move rook has to play there I take and I
could pre move this next formate move I
needed to make sure I had that C pawn
that was a look what I had oh look what
I found move pawn to c5
very timely to control d4 I can got
really active that was an e4 for ye4
versus d6 battle they had a tiny bit
more space no no fixed pawns in the
center
I can got pretty wild
okay hmm let's put the bishop on c4 so
black could go with this little tactic I
don't know if it's it's not as good as
this as if it's the other way around
like cap did to me
reverse colors
we Nandi for I guess we'll just take
in the center or not yes
back here opposite color bishops
so want to flush the night away
guess he's going to take down the bishop
I want to keep my queen on this diagonal
up
upon
yeah let's keep control over this only
open file
I was their King getting active my king
should get rolling now
definitely be stepping up on a capture
okay we definitely cut off the king
don't even want them to get here no way
okay is this too far-fetched
let's find out
the way that's the plan
that is definitely the plan going
forward with the plan it's working it's
working
next scene still a little bit of
thinking
it was tough because they are very weak
on the light squares Bishop on dark
ponds on dark that's what you get it's
how it happens sometimes 44 is each he's
still in the game we didn't get paired
up
he lost against cap only player under
863 in here
all right
first time playing this guy apparently
from Austria
let's see
battle
likely with the d4 d5
let's connect the Knights
you
probably Bishop e7 yeah
I'm gonna go like this I don't want a
castle I think I want my King to kind of
creep up
see how they take
god take with the night if I want to
maintain this palm probably should
how much I like my decision here
let's go
they could push my night
I feel like I don't want to even budge
with the night though like some kind of
sack
let's take how they could take here
20 seconds and other Kings getting
really active
yeah that's the thing
I don't want to
I don't want to move my night
I like having this idea of a push and
then maybe my my king
maybe doing something on e6
here we go what's that move about I
don't want to keep up this square just
can't do it
okay I could take here there is a pin
that mean
you
you
okay they're down on time I didn't know
how to comment on that
I think he's gonna hop back in he's in
pause but he's he's timing it so he gets
a game against me
why is he pause but he's in a game
hmm that's weird
okay any Oh
anyhow we have a Queens gambit declined
exchange variation
another long battle here
maybe in earlier 95 with f5 95 with f4
would have been a nice
for why
let's get out of the pin efore not
we may be gearing up for a four
tell you what I'm gonna jump in
oh my king wants to get ready to bolt
I have paved the way for this
hmm
let's secure it with a piece I guess I
could have done this but let's start
stepping up
hey now I'll do this
now do this
okay I think I'm winning
if this I have the fancy takes clearance
check King d5 game over the other threat
well if the night yeah here's like I get
to do it
I don't know what you call that some
just a clearance I guess
a clearance alright 52 with fire just
shy of 4 minutes remaining
all right I'm getting berserk again
let's get some space
and we're gonna play like this I'm gonna
try and establish
a strong pawn here this is an excellent
position
maintain this point
Oh would you just move already
my knight on f4 I'm gonna take here
Knight on f4 okay they're almost getting
mated
they're made here
it's really close by
let's run it like this now breaking down
the structure guess who's not around to
help trying to do something on the light
squares I could take with the Queen no
it's not made the King could run here
I'm gonna drop on time I guess
that's me hmm okay less than 350 648 39
I guess he's done
game who do you lose to smokey one more
game
we're gonna see its cap in a game no
probably getting this pairing let's see
if I get white or black okay I got white
this time let's see what we get okay an
open Sicilian I don't have much
experience with the open Sicilian with
king of the hill let's keep some pieces
centralized before or not hmm I don't
want to do it man I want to castle too
soon all right
maybe now it's okay to do that this
should be pretty sensitive right
I'm going to get hurt there
or it will move the forward
maybe I should have done that I want my
night to be captured
I want my knight to be captured I want
this square to work with eliminate the
bishop intakes do some fancy stuff now
Bishop check Bishop a to earn a pin
multiple pins this is a wacky position
let me tell you
really wacky position I have that that
mate close come on King do something
exciting
is this working
check oh that's illegal ah man so close
and that's the final game oh man
so close that was so sharp
great game and hopefully er you're
listening to the streamer look back on
it that was a fantastic game what a
sharp middle game okay final standings
56:48 forty eight thirty five thirty to
sixty five and all okay oh and I haven't
been going through the pages see page
two three four or five
all right how many games was that 16 and
all okay to the 64 of you
good games up that's a blast
you